we are live part 2 yeah we back we've
been so Atika the bushes back so we were
doing a final topic of the day Lord King
man what is going on this apex legend I
just want to give my opinion on on a
face it's lit fortnight sucks I gotta go
talk to you thank you thank you sir
later the destroyer of podcast streams
and then fortnight looked over and the
foot man has become unapologetic with a
ripping off this I mean we said there
and we thought that it was a coincidence
with love jeans right now we was showing
the timeline and when they stole stuff
and when stuff was happening and people
was like no you know they independently
made that game and come on man and now
we actually see important I win
they are steady they stole a ping system
outright just boom give me that and then
they actually are stealing characters
like the look-alikes like they're
actually using like it look like schemes
it's like if you plan for tonight
compared to playing apex actually
alright so my question is right now um
is for tonight feeling that pressure
from apex is apex poised to take down
the old champ no what do you all see
with this because yeah I've never seen
anything like this in the history
interest is get in front of
Dave oh yeah let me get on this I mean I
think that apex is a better game like
top to bottom I'd rather play apex I
think you know all the mechanics have
fleshed out way better I think you know
we talked about the ping system we've
talked about you know the gunplay is
good maker from the makers of you know
titanfall
obviously you know good shooter awesome
shooter and titanfall 2 didn't get
enough love I'll just put that out there
and you know if for like people are
saying in the chat like you kind of
alluded to King I mean like fortnight is
you know copying like everything like
anything successful for nine wants to
copy in its you know at the beginning
like they were dominating on Twitch and
stuff but I just took a quick peek while
you're talking King and it looks like
you know four nights back on top and
that regard four nights beating them
right now two-to-one in terms of some of
the streaming numbers but like damn I
mean like it was poised to take over and
they did take over for a while there and
I think the fact that you can just play
for a night on so many different
platforms and you know the kid the kids
playing you know aspect of that I think
for tonight's not gonna be taken down
but I think if anybody could you know
it's probably gonna be apex cuz apex is
also free to play and you know the games
are quick its approachable it's fast
paced it's new it's fresh people love it
so far and like I would love to see apex
take four night down but I think it may
be you know too little too late a little
bit you know mmm yeah it's interesting
it let's get a lord clowns man what do
you think about this whole the apex in
the whole battle world situation with
fortnight well to be honest man apex is
definitely a better game through and
through it's a lot more fun to just get
in there with your friends and play it
also takes more skill to play apex verse
fortnight I think the graphics in apex
is a lot better as well there's just so
many things about apex is a lot better
and apex was dominating fortnight until
season eight came out for night and then
four nights back up right mm-hmm
absolutely
yeah man what about you assassins well
yeah because man I think it just all
depends on what respawn does what their
their games time back you always put out
like weekly updates or weekly you know
skins or
you know there's there always seem to be
really good with that but with respawn
like mmm there's you know they're not
just obviously they they have a career
dedicated the game but you know they
have other things to do others I'm just
apex right right no I pick they can just
work with malware er I mean they have
the PvE but to be honest may be true
that true that JUnit so they they they
have the resources do you just dedicate
the whole time yeah would you say I
meant uh let's get lured kids move
what's that man when you think about
this whole thing is they shuck what's
going on man
alright I just can't wait to fortnight
to die honestly I've never been on the
fortnight bandwagon I get sick you're
tired of going to work but hey Jeep when
I tell them I chose new games they play
you play for now like I mean honestly I
jumped on apex like twice I know addicts
love in that game I really kind of just
didn't fall types I'm sick of these like
battle royale Gear games and but that's
life is going to take another battle
rail game to kill it they so be it i
SPECT a lot out of like the team at
respawn um because they know how to make
a shooter the mechanics are there when I
play very flashy like fortnight is more
than just a game and so I don't know if
a peg is gonna really take it down like
fort nice is having seasons like one
hand go away okay season eight and yeah
back up thank you what did you add they
just literally stole what was a sea of
thieves stealing just straight-up
who was little call these people to the
Mac and get these people from stealing
the game must be insane well yeah did
you kick it I got a lot to say on it I'm
just I just thought about the candid
thing told me what these shooting people
out of cannons and I
yeah where did I see that at what see it
me yeah man I mean listen unless kids
been finished I want a job a kid you go
yeah I'm gonna get less of it
somebody skirt somebody skirt
don't be scurred listen they did all
jokes aside like it's hilarious to me
like for that is so shook of Apex the
blatant copy he is like out of control
it for the season 8 you know they got
the pink the pink system and I just
heard about the respawn bus really that
this is what we doing like wow I just
it's hilarious like I hate to see how
good they are at taking other people's
ideas I'm implementing other people's I
did I mean we've seen a little bit of
this with pub G let's keep it keep it
real you know I'm with kid like I don't
really care about the battle right I
mean a battle royal thing no more but
it's like you know hearing the news of
fortnight kind of scrambling like this
is very entertaining to me I must have
been like they are literally like you
know we have to do what they're doing to
kind of stop this kind of this shift and
I don't know Matt it's gonna be
interesting to see one if apex can keep
this up if they have the mentality to
keep that that pace you know I'm saying
and if fortnight can do something to
kind of counter it to get everybody but
it's not like they're getting there
dominated dominated you don't say
they're still in the mix but it's just
see how reactionary so I'm wit King on
that like yo this is this is crazy that
I've never really seen this level of
every minute so I'm gonna give it back
to you King man what'd you dig ends up
happening keep stealing just like they
said they said okay so the numbers
started to take a dip and we can put our
weekly content and it's been doing it
they have been the best and weekly
content and we Fred let's refresh this
let's keep the apartment they're
churning and so much money I don't know
what their staff look like but brother
they drop in any system school the
existing system without breaking the
foundation of the system is the best
I've ever seen the engine something into
it
anybody they usually all men to bug this
up we got to take it down for this and
not yeah usually with something like
that it's like oh people just think that
they had these things just thought up
beforehand they're just releasing them
in waves after the fact you know you we
usually like harp on games that have DLC
or whatever planned ahead of time and
then they release and it's perfectly
fine and then it comes out that that was
our always in the plan you know I mean
you kind of think to yourself oh why
wasn't that in the game and the in the
forefront but a fortnight it's
completely different it's like you know
they obviously didn't think of this
stuff before and you know that see if
these thing you know see a thieves
caught popularity there with that
controversy would summit and all those
streamers all of a sudden Stein catch on
to see a thieves right now that became
popular and one in four denied do it
copy some of that you know I mean so you
know I don't know how they're getting
away with it but I mean I don't think
people care I think they're just turning
turning the other cheek turn a blind eye
a little bit and just saying hey you
know this thing's popular I'm loving
still playing it and it's something
fresh that you know we get every week
you know
so absolutely fax fast back in a Chasez
nobody knows Unreal Engine better than
epic yeah it shows to their adaptability
man your Lord clowns man can they get
away with this consistently you mean
keep it up new contents the only content
I mean they got the money they got the
power they got the respect nobody is
gonna question them keep doing it people
keep buying it I don't think for
tonight's gonna go anywhere man no
unfortunately I'd like lordotic
or was a kid's move I like to see for
tonight I see I love in this apex
resurgence college yeah yeah yeah with
this all I got bad kid you good go get a
body oh yeah before did I get assassins
that I missus asses
we do I love it alone classic man with
your body here man thanks everybody for
coming back to part two we gonna get
this poll man so yeah a week with the
rumors of a possible upcoming
Borderlands 3 revealed by gearbox which
lunar shooter do you think carries the
mantle of the gold the choices are a
Borderlands the old G and pave the way B
destiny no one does loot and go and play
better C division just a loop mid max
king or D I don't care if me media bias
if anthem isn't crown to go that is it
goes up with its Lords of quarters the
four guys four quarters podcast absolute
pleasure to have you in the building man
as well as kids wolf as well so let's
get the Lords of quarters in here man
Lord infernal lord assassin Lord clowns
where could if I people find you what do
you have going on I mean just every week
you know Thursday is usually around 5:00
5:30 p.m. Eastern we changed that time I
think like 30 episodes or something like
that we we changed we got to episode 200
coming up next week look out for
something special that will be happening
for that we change up I think the format
of the podcast a little bit gonna talk
to these guys a little bit about change
and a little bit of something up to to
make it fresh and differentiate you know
I like to do that but so we'll be doing
that and clowns you want to go ahead and
shout out as well your your venture with
four guys quarters you just recently
started yeah for gwq presents a variant
podcast is every two weeks or every
month depending on our schedules but my
buddy Cody and I we do this thing we
talk about comic books pop culture mm I
have to talk about King statues on there
and we're trying to get Ron Lim on there
for Cognito listen listen
I will have a specially commissioned
statute that I got up that he definitely
uh you get wrong name up there fam that
surfer the power cosmic drawing right
with man let me know bro he loved
working hard on it
that's what's of it assassin the noob
extraordinaire killer mommy car what's
going on look at if I'm people find you
got his you-know-whats I'm gonna find me
on Twitch every day during the week 8
a.m. Central time I stream recently and
firmly in these somebody moat so you can
get your cow and cheese anymote ok I
also do some YouTube things so family
over at Duke you see i underscore
assassin and oh hold on one sec we got
some breaking news before I introduce
kiss well um shaaka
wrap it up I said this just in John
Jones tested positive
oh boy what I hope this ain't something
nude in a picogram we'll get into that
anyway
all eyes I'm waiting Oh Brad don't you
do that Brett you got me killer be right
now Lord small planet Xbox on and our
co-hosts both of our co-hosts the Lord
addict responsible for this wild man
nuking our podcasts a fan oh snap
yeah Daniel snap how do you do this bag
okay well yeah I'm in just do it ma'am
um thanks shouts iron Lords know I gotta
i order my ILP sweater to seem like
spring is taking longer to come um I
also want to UM I celebrated my
blood-borne challenge with Tyler pockets
you guys was there yeah you did it you
completed it that's in Boston and yes I
have another challenge coming up what
you got
it's akiro twice that's gonna be
sometime later this month when the games
available that is the next challenge
proposed same before
like $50 challenge so that's probably
gonna last a month like blood-borne if
I'm able to do it so wish me the best of
luck to that no plan Xbox will return
but this week we got new member oh um
I'm okay you don't want debut it right
now I would love to debut it but um deal
yeah so talk can't work this way okay
okay yeah anything that what about the
existing characters who remains
everybody right everybody remains I mean
obviously I mean unfortunately you know
we lost frogs someone's back right so
far uh so but it's still you know the
best spot attic grinds my gears meds
next person that's coming I will give
you a hint here's from a popular podcast
so um I don't know if you guys watching
the Xbox section so that's all I got
Wednesday's 8:30 p.m. Eastern or you
know black people time 8:47 p.m. doubt
the planet xbox I'm glad you add 8 cups
nut about people say I got my bad man
still in there is still in there you
know what you say a lot of times they
look like you know what it's every time
then you'll notice every time the
roasting gets worse he just destroyed
the whole joy was like take it down
if you guys don't bring master cheese
back combat talk with the king coming up
remember I'm only gonna give you stuff
that I watched when Helen was selfish
with that that's my joint so I'm gonna
give you the real on that face that you
want to look at a spice that you want to
see I'm not a gossip column so I don't
really care if Floyd Mayweather is
wearing Gucci or not my thing I'm not a
gossip column um cater statues notice
every Wednesday to be dropped out new
ones at nine o'clock in the morning that
don't fire would you get you're gonna
get like two of them so like if you
watch one and you just want to see the
unboxing and just listen to the beat
while you clean in the house and you
want to listen to me talk I don't care
you will see I got something for you
right there you can watch that part
without me but if you want to hear
something about it I'm not gonna go into
the history of Batman I'm not doing it
why I like it and why it's there all
right so we got something that's gonna I
swear come up next is going to appeal to
that child and each and every one of us
okay okay I make you sing man is really
got this and you gotta say that it's in
his house they all envious man we all
every is Kos best collections is covered
so that new one has debuting coming up
and we got a week away from that always
they said Wednesday sweats the plug baby
what's the plug Wednesday 7:00 a.m. so
that you go to Lourdes gaming dad so you
can definitely check that out there you
can check it out on Instagram Facebook I
put it everywhere but you're not gonna
get full thing unless you go to that
YouTube channel yes I'm giving you slip
bits on Twitter
bits on Facebook I'm giving you snippets
on Instagram just the wet show pilot and
then you get the real YouTube sir that's
what's up K what's coming man killing it
with that love what you do I make
thanks everyone for sticking around
while like so many people came back
that's what's up everybody student again
salute to the four guys recorders
podcast man huge fan I'm so glad we able
to do this joint little venture you know
saying and I love these guys I've always
wanted promote the positive guys
infernal I'm trying to smash infernal
I'm gonna take them out to eat you go
get that macaroni this as well as
fashions contain your main protect you
man the premium yo watch out for him
we don't be enforced the Lord's will be
at PAX East so we go get a chance to
hang out with it further what is
absolutely man actually you know if King
if King wants to snatch Inferno you know
do some things or whatever as long as in
envelopes come my way will bounce with
the stick it's absolutely hilarious
today this is a classic episode but yeah
man please support these brothers and
make sure man you guys are there what's
that time inferno
wait was it Thursday Thursday Thursday
5:30 p.m. they're gonna be episode 200
get your behinds in that channel man
celebrate these dude this is a huge
accomplishment for these guys that's
twice as much as the Lord's informative
conference conversation always
intelligent great good people man we
love you guys out there man so please
support before guys recorders podcast is
really good bunch of guys man but yeah
that's what I got man subscribed like
all that good stuff with us you already
know Spotify iTunes SoundCloud card box
we'll have that up in the description
again shout out to my brother carboxyl
on that that's gonna be going up and
make sure everybody knows the Lords of
gaming dotnet it's up there all your
latest gaming news opinion pieces game
walkthroughs you know I'm saying shall
the Disney chat very strong launch week
very proud
we got some hot uncouple coming scribes
man shout out yo shout out rally Shaka
mods gaming and relevant native gondolas
condor frost
zero biggie jerseys out here killing it
with these articles man we got some more
surprises coming soon right
magneto before you go yeah I found the
headquarters to saber interactive Oh me
and you are about twenty minutes away
from them there they're gonna pull out
World War Z they've gotta pull out World
War Z we got do that brother hopefully
kid we can get you in beat down the
night before you know you know the ILP
castle travels we travel heavy
so again if you need space if it's a
last-minute thing let us know man we got
should we got it you could do the psych
Road right you know a lava Greg you know
you got the good luck yeah man and again
I want to shout out a couple shout outs
then we get out of here I wanna shout
the stream team man they really killing
it some great ILP first looks addicts
has a tremendous one up there with
Earthling shout out the snarl though
l-boogie was in the chat old-school
style MJ the boss and of course Lord
Allah PO the potentially perfect one
himself um MJ we're gonna start training
getting you up I'm getting you ready
we're gonna do a rocky music when
they're ready for assassin we could do
the full guy scores versus IOP young gun
is to be easier on us ass be easy at
least the last word 51 woody boxes we
had a super special guest Lord scare Oh
9 actually great guest man talked a lot
was going overseas on a drift of all
that blue boxes power went out man I
can't shoot at the Texas rose oh look
I love to support that is all I got
thank you everyone
enjoy your Sunday stick finger yes it's
finished it's finished just we'll go one
of 101 and you're going to laugh like
you've never laugh any before after what
Lord addict has done anyway everyone
enjoy your Sunday and peace planet